- [Voiceover] In 1865,
Mendel, often considered
the father of modern genetics, comes up
with a structured way of thinking about
these inheritable factors,
which we now call "genes."
And then as we go into the early 1900's,
his work was rediscovered, and people
started to say, "Okay, we see how some
"of these traits get passed on in these
"somewhat predictable ways, we can put
"some structure around it, but what is
"the actual biological mechanism for that?
"How are these traits
encoded at a cellular,
"or at a molecular level?"
And so, in 1902, and we talked about this
in a previous video,
Boveri and Sutton come up
with the Chromosome Theory, based on
seeing how chromosomes separate and pair
during cell division, and saying,
"Hey, those seem to map up quite well
"to what Mendel described
by these heritable factors."
Then we start having a lot
more evidence for this.
Morgan is able to show that a mutant
eye color trait seems to be passed on
in a way that shows that it is on
the X sex chromosome, and he and his team
start doing a lot more work,
especially with fruit flies,
to show that, "Hey,
chromosomes are the basis
"for where these heritable factors are."
But then even within the chromosomes,
people weren't sure, chromosomes were made
up of protein, made up of DNA, what was
the molecule or the set
of molecules that actually
encoded for these heritable traits?
And at first, most of the weight was on
the protein side, because
proteins were these
complex molecules that
had all of this variety
that seemed that it could code
for these heritable traits, while DNA,
at least early on, seemed like a kind of
boring molecule, people assumed
that there wasn't a lot
of diversity in DNA.
They assumed that even if you go from
one species to another
that the DNA molecule
was fundamentally the same.
So early on, people
actually were on the side
more of the proteins.
But then more and more evidence came
on DNA's side, you had
Griffith's experiment,
where he was able to
show, "Hey, I could take
"this heat-killed
bacteria, but if I mix it
"with some other living
bacteria that somehow
"there's some transformation principle
"that transforms the
living bacteria into the
"type of species that I had heat-killed."
And you go to 1944 and Avery, McCarty,
and MacLeod are able to
show some pretty good
evidence that the actual principle,
the thing that was left in
that heat-killed bacteria,
was probably DNA.
And then we get even
more conclusive evidence
with the experiments of Hershey and Chase
and we have a whole video on this.
Where they say, "Hey what is it that
"viruses inject into bacteria to hijack
"their genetic system?"
And they say, "Hey, it's not proteins!
"It is DNA that does this."
So they provide much more conclusive
evidence on the side of DNA.
But even at that point, we as a community,
as a civilization, still didn't know what
the actual structure of DNA was.
We also did not know,
how did that structure
actually code for all of
these heritable factors?
And the work culminates
with Watson and Crick,
but it was dependent on all of the people
I mentioned, and more.
And one person who
should get special credit
for, one, getting a
little bit more evidence
on the side of DNA and helping Watson
and Crick, actually
there's several people.
But, in particular, Chargaff,
and Rosalind Franklin,
and Rosalind Franklin
in particular probably does not get
as much credit as she deserves.
Chargaff's the one that showed,
DNA actually is more interesting than
people appreciated.
He noticed that the frequencies
of the nitrogenous bases of adenine,
guanine, cytosine, and thymine
in DNA varies across species.
And, something that's somehow coding
for what makes a species a species,
well, it would have to vary across species
so that makes DNA interesting.
And then the other thing that he noticed,
and this was key for
Watson and Crick's work,
is that the frequency of guanine is equal
to the frequency of cytosine in DNA,
and the frequency of adenine is equal
to the frequency of thymine in DNA.
And so it's a clue that these somehow
are associated with
each other, they somehow
pair with each other.
And so we get to the early '50's.
We had all of this evidence that DNA
is the molecular basis, you have Chargaff
with his rules called Chargaff's Rules,
and then you have Rosalind Franklin,
and she's imaging diffraction patterns
from X-rays beamed into crystals of DNA.
So what I mean by crystal of DNA,
a crystal is taking a bunch of molecules
and arranging them in a regular pattern.
So a crystal of DNA,
that's one DNA molecule,
then you have another
DNA molecule, and then
you have another DNA molecule,
and then you beam X-rays at them,
and X-rays are key because the wavelength
of an X-ray is small enough to capture
the features at an atomic level.
So you beam X-rays and
then the X-rays diffract.
And then you capture the
pattern of that diffraction.
And then depending on the structures
in the actual molecules you'll have
different diffraction patterns.
And Franklin's famous diffraction pattern
is shown right over here, and when she
immediately saw this, it had some
of the telltale cues
for a helical structure.
Now, I wouldn't read too much into this
if you're not an expert reader of X-ray
diffraction patterns,
this isn't a direct image
of a DNA molecule, but they knew,
she already knew and in fact people
in this community already knew that
this X pattern was a telltale sign
for a helical structure of some kind,
and then they were also able to look
at the other clues here to think about,
"What's the spacing between
different molecules?"
And even the spacing between the different
turns of the helix structure.
Now once again, this diffraction pattern
is not a direct image.
It's a very well-develped expertise
to backwards map how things will diffract
into the thing that actually
caused the diffraction.
And they would take it from multiple
different angles to get
a better understanding
of it and actually
today, you have computers
doing this that could
take a diffraction pattern
and start to construct what the electron
clouds of what the actual
molecule looks like.
So Franklin, this was painstaking work,
and she already had a sense,
she knew it was a helical structure but
she was waiting to get a little bit more
evidence before she published her work.
Now at the same time, you have Watson
and Crick here, who were
trying to solve the structure.
And they got a hold of Franklin's work
with the help of Maurice Wilkins here,
who Franklin worked with.
And they were able to establish
that it wasn't a single helix,
but it was a double helix.
And you actually had these base pairs
forming the rungs of the double helix,
and that was really interesting because
that showed how DNA
could replicate itself,
how it could contain actual information.
And we go into much much more depth
in two future videos.
Now the sad part about this story is,
Wilkins, Watson, and Crick went on to win
a Nobel prize, Franklin unfortunately died
very young and you're
not allowed to receive
a Nobel prize if you've passed away.
So she's very deserving of it.
This work, which a lot of people consider
to be one of the biggest discoveries
in science, was based on what she did.
Arguably, had Watson and Crick not had
access to her work, they would not have
been able to figure it
out, and if she'd just
stuck to what she was doing without
other people having accessed her work,
she might have been
able to get to that same
conclusion, so she is
one of the people who,
sometimes, the history
of science overlooks.
But this isn't to not give credit to
Watson and Crick either, there were still
a lot of very powerful intuitive leaps
that they had to make to come up with this
double helix structure, this anti-parallel
double helix structure where they go
in opposite directions, but they bridge
with these nitrogenous bases
pairing with each other.
And this is a big, big, big, big deal.
Throughout most of human history, we knew
that traits were passed on but traits
seemed like this magical mystical thing.
"I know my laugh is like my dad's,
"but how is that actually
encoded in my DNA?"
And now, we're able to see that a lot
of what we consider
about ourselves to be us,
is encoded in these molecules and encoded
in these base pairs, so it's beautiful,
it's incredible, it's
shedding light on one
of the biggest mysteries
of what makes humans,
actually all life, life.